A true artist will do anything for their craft
and for actors in Hollywood that sometimes
means putting their bodies through some pretty
intense stuff.
Whether they are beefing up to play superheroes
or shedding pounds to portray junkies, some
of your favorite actors have a serious history
of transforming their bodies.
For this video we are taking a look at some
of the best in our list of 10 Popular Actors
Who Made CRAZY Transformations For Their Roles.
Enjoy this video and before you leave, be
sure to hit the subscribe button for more
great Screen Rant content, every single day!
Chris Pratt – Guardians Of The Galaxy
Remember the days of chubby Chris Pratt making
us laugh on Parks and Recreation?
If you don’t, pause this video and go watch
all sevens seasons immediately!
After Chris Pratt was cast to play Star lord
in Guardians Of The Galaxy, he took it upon
himself to get into great shape, and did he
ever!
The actor lost 60 pounds and transformed himself
from the funny fat guy to the jacked leading
man that he is today.
Since his transformation, Pratt has been landing
leading roles left, right and center with
great performances in movies like Passengers,
The Magnificent Seven and Jurassic World.
The craziest part about his weight loss story
is that Guardians Of The Galaxy director James
Gunn didn’t even ask him to lose weight
for the part.
With all the success and health the change
has brought him, we are guessing Pratt is
happy with his decision!
Anne Hathaway – Les Miserables
For years, Anne Hathaway was always considered
to be a pretty girl who makes for a fun and
non-threatening lead in a romantic comedy.
Then, in 2012, Hathaway flipped the script
and delivered a bone chilling performance
in Les Miserables.
Although she only mustered about 20 minutes
of screen time, she was able to take home
the honors for Best Supporting Actress at
The Academy Awards.
This was surely due to her fantastic acting,
singing and crazy physical transformation.
Hathaway went from the girl next door to the
troll under the bridge by losing 25 pounds,
having her hair cut short and putting in disgusting
fake teeth.
By the time she dies in the movie, she is
almost completely unrecognizable.
Christian Bale – The Machinist
Christian Bale is one of the most talented,
respected and honestly feared actors working
today.
He’s made headlines for outstanding performances
and outlandish on set outbreaks but there
is no denying that he fully commits himself
in to every role he does.
Bale is no stranger to changing his body for
his movies as he put on a insane amount of
muscle to play The Dark Knight and turned
himself into a pudgy slob for American Hustle.
His craziest transformation, however, came
when he was preparing for his role in The
Machinist when he dropped a terrifying 63
pounds.
He did his with an dangerously low calorie
intake and he apparently wanted to lose even
more weight but doctors had to say no.
The skeleton-like photos of Bale are now iconic
and are just another reason why he is such
an amazing talent.
Charlize Theron – Monster
Charlize Theron is the type of beautiful where
she can walk into a room in a ball gown and
time seems to stop.
The actress has been glowing on the big screen
for years now and even in her gritty one-armed
performance as Furiosa in Mad Max, she still
has that beautiful look.
That is why her transformation for the movie
Monster is so impressive as she was able to
become seriously unattractive.
For the film Theron gained a whopping 30 pounds,
shaved off her eyebrows and added in some
gross fake teeth.
All of this work makes the actress pretty
scary looking and definitely helped her secure
her Oscar for Best Actress.
Mila Kunis and Natalie Portman – Black Swan
Black Swan is truly exciting psychological
thriller that, through ballet, gives the audience
a window into the world of obsession and psychological
breakdowns.
Natalie Portman and Mila Kunis are great in
the film, but they have been very vocal about
how difficult their roles really were.
No, we’re not talking about the sex scene
between the two of them (again), we’re talking
about the fact that they each lost 20 pounds
and were forced to train for 6 hours a day,
7 days a week.
Both of these women are slim to begin with,
so shedding off another 20 pounds must have
been a serious chore and both Kunis and Portman
have spoken about the pain they were in from
all the starving.
Jared Leto – Chapter 27, Dallas Buyers Club
When you decide to take on the role of The
Joker, you have to know that you will become
of the most talked about actors in all of
Hollywood, and that is exactly what happened
with Jared Leto.
But the truth is, Leto had a long list of
great and even academy awarding winning roles
long before Suicide Squad.
Leto is definitely not afraid to throw all
of himself into a part and he made that clear
when he became almost unrecognizable after
gaining a whopping 67 pounds for his leading
role in Chapter 27.
Then, after he got back to his normal weight,
he proceeded to lose an additional 40 pounds
for his role in Dallas Buyers Club, the part
that would land him the Oscar for Best Supporting
Actor.
Say what you will about his performance as
the clown prince of Gotham, but nobody can
deny that Leto can transform his body for
his artform!
Adam Driver – Silence
Adam Driver is probably best known as Kylo
Ren, the big bad in Star Wars The Force Awakens
and likely the next episodes as well.
Driver is an interesting guy as his career
features a wide range of roles from raunchy
comedies to heavy dramas and everything in
between.
The world will really get a look at Driver’s
acting chops when they get to see Martin Scorsese’s
new film, Silence.
In the film, Driver plays a Jesuit priest
and from the trailers and clips that have
come out, it is clear that he lost an enormous
amount of weight for the part.
Driver looks skeletal and he has told the
press that not only were he and his costar
Andrew Garfield asked to lose weight for the
start of filming, but they were required to
continue to lose weight throughout the filming
process as well.
This definitely sounds like a lot of work
but when you are an up and coming actor and
you land a leading role in a Scorsese film,
you do what you got to do.
Jason Segal – The Five-Year Engagement
Jason Segal is on hilarious dude and his performance
as Marshall Eriksson on How I Met Your Mother
is one for the ages.
Segal has never really been known as a particularly
fat or skinny or jacked guy so it is somewhat
surprising to hear about his body transformation.
Apparently, when preparing to film The Five
Year Engagement Jason Segal actually dropped
35 pounds as he felt that it would make him
a more believable match for the stunning Emily
Blunt.
This is a somewhat shocking number, but we
have to give it to the actor for trying to
bring authenticity to the role, even if the
movie probably didn’t deserve it.
Jonah Hill – 21 Jump Street
Could you imagine losing 40 pounds and then
still having to play “The Fat Guy”?
Well, that is exactly what happened to Jonah
Hill in 21 Jump Street.
The actor is known to fluctuate in weight
just about as much as he fluctuates between
Oscar movies and stoner comedies, but for
his role opposite Channing Tatum in 21 Jump
Street he really shed some pounds.
Hill is never going to be the ripped leading
man, especially standing next to the specimen
that is Tatum, but it was cool to see him
as a more lean and mobile character.
The movie is a really great action/comedy
and Hill’s weight loss allowed him to be
more believable both as a cop and as a high
school student.
The next Jump Street movie is currently in
the works and will reportedly be a cross over
with the Men In Black franchise.
Margot Robbie – Tonya Harding
Lately, Margot Robbie’s name, face and body
have been popping up all over the place and
with the fantastic job that she did in 2016’s
Suicide Squad, we can understand why.
While her Harley Quinn costume may have sparked
some serious controversy, there is no denying
that the Australian actress looked smoking
hot in that outfit.
Well, fans of Robbie and stunning looks may
be shocked to see what she is looking like
these days.
The actress is currently filming her role
as infamous figure skater Tonya Harding and
a photo that surfaced online has Robbie looking
disheveled and pudgy.
It sounds like she is just wearing a fat suit
and some prosthetics but it really is shocking
to see such a bombshell looking that bad.
We are guessing that this look was just for
a particular part of the movie and that Robbie
will be looking great in those skating outfits
for most of the film!
So there is our list of 10 popular actors
who made insane transformations for their
movie roles.
Which one of these stories impresses you the
most?
What other crazy transformations have you
heard about?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
fun videos – like this one!